[音楽]
よろしくお願いします
僕です
&ARアーティストという
肩書きでですね今活動していますARって
いうのは最近Appleも発表しましたが
来年の初頭に
ARグラスが出ると僕は何かこの
テクノロジーが痛いんではなく
ARは何の略かというと
拡張現実なんですよ現実を
拡張するオーグメント
リアリティなんですねこの実際今目の前に
起きている現実を
縮小するも
拡張するも自分次第だと
あなた次第だとで僕自身はですね地元は
ここ
愛知県出身なんですここに立たせて
もらえることまず
めちゃくちゃ光栄に思っています僕愛知県
出身なんでどれだけいかに名古屋大学が
素晴らしいかというのはですね
親戚特におじいちゃんおばあちゃん
めちゃくちゃちっちゃい時から言われまし
た
メディアに入れはもうこれ以上にゃーって
言われてほとんどあの
猫に喋りかけてるのかなってくらいみゃー
にゃーだったんですけどどっちなんだろう
と思いながらはいそんな僕
剣と森がまさか2023年このレッツ
ザッツのこの赤い
太陽のようなカーペットの上に建てると
いうことは本当に光栄に思ってますという
わけで僕の今回持ってきた
ZX名古屋ユーにおいてのトピックスは
出てますねこちら
夢と愛
でなぜかこれをなぜ僕が
を一つキーワードにしたかというと
今回の
テレックス名古屋
youこれが
日本語で言うと超新星爆発スーパー
ノーブラ
これがテーマだってこと聞いたんでこの超
新星爆発を
起こすためには
俺に何があったっけなーと思ったら
これしかなかったです
なぜなら
僕今38なんですけど
口で自分で言ってても38ってマジかと
思うんですけど
30なくて8歳なんじゃないかなと思うん
ですけど
38なんですよ
びっくりしたやばいこれこそがまさに超
新星爆発違うはいなんですけど
[音楽]
25歳の時に自叙伝を出したんですよその
時のタイトルがJOINandlove
だったんですよで僕にとっての超新星爆発
を本当の意味で体感
感じさせてくれたの
その時ですねまだ
健在だった
僕にとってのヒーロー今まで人類で最も
最高のスーパースターの一人なんじゃない
かというマイケルジャクソンという存在に
出会いそして
専属ダンサー契約を一瞬だけだったんです
けど数日だけなんですけどさせてもらえた
時に
それを振り返ると僕の夢これ表裏一体で夢
に対する愛情愛と夢と愛これをもってして
僕自身が人生を拡張しそして
超新星爆発を起こしていたんだと思うん
ですねそれをしていった先に
夢の場所にたどり着けてそれをその
プロセスを綴ったのが
という自叙伝なんですよこれ別に別に本の
宣伝をしてるわけじゃないんですけど事実
当時書いていたことそれが今この超新星
爆発スーパーノヴァって言われたのでこれ
を出しましたで一つ
字を変換したいんですよこの超新星爆発
スーパー新しい
星
爆発ですけど僕は超
シンは心
心そして性は
生きる
爆発だと
あえて
理解しています
それはなぜかというとこの超新星爆発を
起こすも起こさないも僕はその鍵になるの
は
これだと思ってます
それをちょっとイメージしてみてください
髪の毛こっちがDreamこっちがラブ
そうこっちがラブでもいいんですよこっち
がドリームでもいいですよはいというわけ
ではないんですけどDream
夢の表裏一体選ぶではちょっと具体的な話
をしようかなと思う僕は名古屋大学には
言ってませんでしたただ大学生になって
ましたで大学を3年間行くんですよで残り
1年っていうところで
夢留学みたいな夢進学ってことでアメリカ
ロサンゼルスに行きまして今に至ります
もう17年経ちました18年目です今で
今日なんといつ日本に通りだったかという
とですね今日の朝5時です
僕20時間前までロサンゼルスいました
フライト1時20分
LXはい11時間20分飛行機乗るはい
羽田朝5時タクシー乗る朝6時20分の新
幹線乗る8時8分新名古屋駅そして車を
走らせ朝9時のリハーサルに間に合ってる
んですよ20時間あればロサンゼルスから
ここ
夢の場所から日本日本から夢の場所簡単に
行き来できるんですよでそんな僕が自分の
実体験をするにあたってまず
今もなお
夢の中に僕は生きているつもりなんです
けどそれをするにあたって超新星爆発心が
生まれる
その爆発は
自分の中の
心の中で
一生に1回の人生で
これ本当に改めて当たり前のこと言うよう
ですけど僕も二度とないと思ってる
ステージです
でこの瞬間
唯一できるのはこの超新星爆発だと思うん
ですよ
それをするにあたって
心の中に
占めてる
Wants
これをしたいんだというものが
僕普段から
なるべく100であることを心がけてるん
ですね
なぜなら
当時
振り返ると学生時代
一生に1回しかない人生の中で
どこか
いろんな方々のアドバイスがこう生きて
いる上でありましてこうすると幸せだああ
すると幸せだこうなるとみんなが賞賛する
ああなるとみんなが喜ぶということを
いろいろ聞くこともあったんですけど
実際一番自分が
最後大切にしたかったのは僕の心がどう
思うかなぜなら一生に1回の人生だから
そこで人生の歩み方の中にhavetoと
いうしなければいけないっていうものを
なるべく減らす作業をここまでしてきたん
ですなぜなら一生に1回の人生でhave
to
やらなきゃいけない事ってありますかもし
かしたらあるのかもしれないけどそれを
wanttoにした場合にしなきゃいけ
ないこれは仕事だから
ちなみに僕ここ2年ぐらい僕の職業を無職
って呼んでるんですよ
ぜひ笑ってください
でも無職の無は
夢だから英語で言うとドリーマーなんです
このジュリーマーであるために
常にプライスレス今もまさにこのプライス
レスを感じれる場所なんですけれどもこの
プライスレスはどんなお金よりもどんな
仕事よりも買うか勝つどんな仕事よりも
勝ってしまうこの夢ごとっていう次元これ
がWantsそのWantsの先に
wouldlove2愛してやまないだ
からこれをずっとやっていたいんだそう
いう人生の歩み方そういう時間の使い方を
僕はしたいと思ったんですそれはなぜかと
いうと今もですけど僕パーソナルなことを
言うと刻一刻とですよ
僕のね愛するおばあちゃんが
病院で寝たきりでいつ何時何が起きるか
わからないっていうの状況なんですけど
そんなおばあちゃんが当時昔よく言ってた
んですよ僕に
人が
死ぬ気になりゃ
できにゃーことはにゃ
にゃーがめっちゃあったと思うんですけど
人が死ぬ気になればできないことはないっ
ていうのを
農業をずっと
専業
百姓農業やってるおばあちゃんが言ってて
で僕はその言葉すごい言葉だなと
血抜きになるような思いで一つのこと自分
のやりたいワンツーをやれば簡単に言うと
あなたの夢が何であれ叶うんださっき冒頭
で言ったように僕にとってヒーローだった
マイケルジャクソンと会ってしまったそれ
もマイケル」って言ってコンサートで手
振ったんではなく彼の専属ダンサーとして
握手できた彼の前で名前を呼ばれた彼に
よって選ばれたこんな事っていうのは人生
振り返ってもすごく自信になって今に至る
んですねってことは僕思ったんですよ不
可能は何一つないでもじゃあ不可能を可能
にするかまたは不可能のままにするかは
自分
自分の心の中にある
夢と愛この中にhave2を消してワン
ツーだけにしてった先に
人間の本来ある最高最も幸せなパワーが
生まれるんじゃないかそれこそがまさに超
新星爆発超新星爆発生きている感覚My
horiesborning
僕息子に歌ってもらってるんですけど
超新星爆発は何かつったら生きてる感覚僕
の
息子は名前がまさにライブって言って
生きる
IBE生中継でよく使うライブなんですよ
これもライブなんですよ僕フリッカー使わ
なかったですなぜなら台本なく今喋ってる
んですよどこからかここからそれが直接
届くんじゃないかって思いでおばあちゃん
で言う死ぬ気でこのステージに立ってる
その時に
息子に与えたかったのは何をしてくれても
でも生きてるって思って欲しいと思って
生きてる感覚それでライブって言うんです
けど光りまうまさにこれ超新星爆発生き
てる感覚myheart僕の心は
太陽みたいに燃え盛るそれこそがまさに
It'saBIG
Bこの
宇宙が生まれたっていうことなんじゃない
かとだからこの宇宙っていうのは138億
年前に生まれたいや僕自身まさに今回の
テーマスーパーノヴァがそうなんですけど
超新星爆発ビッグペンは今この瞬間からで
も僕はいつでも起こせると思っていてそれ
が
夢に対する
爆発これは
ウランや
プルトニウムでやる
核融合ではなく
夢と愛の
爆発なんじゃないかそれを持ってすれば
みんなが座るべき席に座り
夢に向かって何一つ
自分の
1回しかない
奇跡かける奇跡かける奇跡かける奇跡の
この無限の可能性の中で最高の
目標達成に
至れるんじゃないかなと思ってそんな
ところからですね
僕自身何を求めるか人類皆がそうやって
生きていった先に
世界平和という
僕の大いなる目標
達成に向かっていけるんじゃないかと思っ
て僕は実はこのステージに立たせてもらっ
ています
ダンス僕は
踊りというものをプロとしてで言うと今
18年目になります22歳の時に
アーティストビザというのはアメリカで
取得して22歳同じ年にマドンナという
この前ちょっとねなんかあの体調崩して
るって言ったんですけど彼女の
専属ダンサーを2年間やりながらそこから
今に至るんですけれども
踊りっていうものは
昨日いたロサンゼルスもそうですしここも
そうですけど人種
宗教
国境文化年齢
全てを超えて
鼓動を合わせて一つになれる人類みな兄弟
だって感じれるんですと同時に
不可能はないんだと思わせてくれる
この感覚こそが
体を取らずとも心躍る心技体心躍ることで
超新星爆発につながりそして
夢に向かって
実現する愛が生まれて世界が
鏡の前の自分から変わるんじゃないかなと
いうふうに思って
それこそがまさに
[音楽]
Everything全ての出来事には
理由があるということで最後皆さんにこの
夢と愛っていうのは僕はお金で買えない
価値プライスです人生で絶対に
プライスレスな体験をっていう思いで一緒
に最後
踊りたいんですよ
もらうのは
座ったままでいいです両手だけですその時
に
ピース皆さんできますかピースください
起きたピースをイエイイエイイエイそし
たらこれピースでもあるんですけど僕日本
は家ですよね家んYのイメージでこのYを
右手からピョンピョン
振ってくださいせーの
したら次左でせーのイェイイェンせーの
じゃんけんもう一回行くよ
左
イェイ
お金なんていらねえよと
会ってそうはないんですけどねでもお金を
追うんではなくて夢を追った先にお金は
ついてくると思うのでそしたら世の中って
みんな結構イェイイエーってなりがちだよ
ねと
ダンス同じようにチップもらってもイェイ
イエーってなりがちなんですけどいや
そんなつもりで踊ってたんじゃない家々
って意味で次は両手でしっかりパンチを空
に向かってせーの
イェイイェイやったら次はいやでもいら
ないですって断ってくださいせーのいえ
いえ
100人のダンサーここにいますよ皆さん
素晴らしいOKでは
僕音楽と共に誘導しますから皆さんそし
たらいやいやいやいやいやいやいやいや
OkOk
[音楽]
ではちょっと待って見てて
いやいやいやいや
ありがとう
世界を一つにする魔法そして
夢で
みんなが一つになる世界を僕は心から願っ
ていますありがとうございました
ThankYou
Thankyou
thankyou